[Applause]
i don't think
conor mcgregor wants it anymore um
yeah i think it's over and i think
if he has to fight elite competition or
uh people who are hungry
he will lose continually because he's
not going to dig deep anymore to do it
and why should he is 100 million dollars
anybody with that type of money
shouldn't be fighting
you have to be literally crazy you have
to have a psychotic desire for attention
to be worth a hundred million dollars
and want to continue fighting
floyd mayweather has that yeah he's also
the most skilled
athlete that we've ever seen in terms of
their discipline
so he can get away with it but like once
you have 100 million dollars
the drive to fight to put yourself
at risk when you have a beautiful family
at home
a wife a lifestyle you did everything
you ever wanted to do you've
accomplished everything you ever wanted
the only reason you have to continue
fighting is because you are addicted to
the attention and i don't know
if mayweather not maybe i don't know if
mcgregor is mayweather yes
but i don't think mcgregor is i truly
don't think he is i think he's a little
bit more like self-actualized than
mayweather
and i think he likes the attention don't
get me wrong but even in the way that he
was like
talking to dustin he almost like liked
him
he was almost like happy for dustin's
victory it was a different
connor it seemed like yeah friendly yeah
whatever you should be friendly when
you're worth a hundred million dollars
you should want dustin's uh hot sauce
business to be successful you should
think dustin is a good family man and
like uh has this charity that's really
trying to help
disenfranchise people like you should
want that when you have all that money
you should want to help people
but you shouldn't be in the business of
knocking them unconscious right
you don't have you need to be hungry you
need to be starving
dustin is fine financially i assume but
he's
starving when you saw him in there that
was a starving
[ __ ] dog apparently he said some [ __ ]
after the fight like
i don't even want to fight anymore but
i'm damn i'm just so [ __ ] good at it
yeah i'm a dog
he's a and he could say that he doesn't
like it
i think what he didn't like and he kind
of expounded on that a little bit he
said uh
he didn't like the two weeks of like
quarantine in the hotel okay i think
mcgregor was brilliant just renting the
yacht
because now you're not locked in a
[ __ ] hotel room for two weeks you're
like enjoying
this massive yacht that he's staying out
that was right in front of what looked
like the facility
so like you're basically outside you're
hanging out you're doing whatever you
want to do
you're not in a hotel room like dustin
it has a fire flex too you're walking up
to the venue you see this massive yeah
you're like
also imagine it's right outside the
window from dustin yeah i gotta fight
that guy you gotta fight that one but
you know what that's motivation for
dustin yeah that's what i would think i
would think it's like i'm gonna [ __ ]
this guy up
bro listen dustin is no slouch don't get
me wrong but
connor i i truly think you reach some
sort of financial threshold where it is
not worth it you get punched in the face
a few times when you have 100 million
and you're like what am i
doing well i want to remember what my
kids tell me
i want to remember it well he might not
after saturday
real talk i mean there will come a time
if football continues to grow in
popularity and they start making more
and more and more money
where you will see football players and
it's already started to happen
but you'll see more and more football
players retire right now it's hard for
them to accumulate that type of [ __ ] you
wealth
in in a short span especially uh you
know certain positions that
don't get paid really that much like i'm
what is the top lineman getting paid
70 for like six years or whatever so you
look it's really good money don't get me
wrong but you got to put your body
through punishment for six years yeah
and once they start making that [ __ ] you
money you're gonna see short careers man
in and out this is not worth it i'm
telling you man
it is you can't be worth that amount of
money
and still maintain your success level
unless you have a
serious addiction to attention i agree
with you
something in conor has definitely
changed like um
he used to be the king of the trolling
[ __ ] yeah like
he should be eating away at this whole
logan paul situation like
they could have been going back and
forth jake paul whatever
and make this [ __ ] super interesting but
you can tell
his responses to those videos were oh
hey here's a video of me with my kid
and we we with my family like you see
what matters to him now
and when he was in that ring like i told
akash's right in the beginning of the
fight i was like yo he's not fighting
with confidence
yeah he's not fighting where it's like
he knows he can level a [ __ ] out
with his jab like
he was fighting a little scared and
that's like it's not the same guy
anymore it's not the same guy and i'll
be honest
i don't think he's a as dominant at this
weight class
i think that he is his competitive
advantage
is 145 pounds he is
incredibly powerful at 145 pounds
cannot take his punch at 145 pounds at
guys start being able to take his punch
especially the bigger 155 pounders right
and he doesn't have the gas tank
to go long enough to get that decision
right so
his competitive advantage was lights out
you're going to sleep he sleeps guys at
145 no problem
smaller 150 fibers maybe he sleeps them
but if he even tried to go up to 170
you're not asleep look what look what he
did to uh nate diaz now he has an
amazing chin
he knocks him down a bunch but you're
not putting him to sleep it's not lights
he's 155 to 170. but nate will fight
comfortably at 170 he's a big 155 okay
right so now he doesn't have this
competitive advantage and he doesn't
have the cardio to take him into those
later rounds
and then seeing what happened with
dustin like he landed a couple shots
i think he had dustin hurt once but he
didn't realize it yeah he there was a
time where he had to hurt yeah
he had a left that hit him good and i
think justin even said afterwards he hit
me with one shot that was hard and if he
followed up i could have been in trouble
but i just don't think he [ __ ] needs
it anymore
yeah and people talk about the lower leg
kick which seems to be a uh
a trend now in mma i don't know if you
realize to like with izzy
yeah izzy did it against paula costa
even before that
uh with romero yep the thigh but uh
izzy's teammate uh volkanovsky
did it against max holloway in their
first fight
and really stopped max holloway and it's
a way to mitigate boxers and guys who
come straight forward
right because in order to come straight
forward you got to put a little pressure
on that front leg yeah if they're
sitting down on that front leg they
can't check it yeah
as easy especially guys who have a
really good jab you're stomping that jab
and if you're [ __ ] cracking away
dustin uh poirier said it as well but uh
justin gaichi said it when he was
fighting khabib he goes
if i had him almost hurt and out of here
you're like what what are you talking
about
but what he's referring to is those leg
kicks if you land a few leg kicks
gaichi said he's like if i land four or
five leg kicks you can't move
yeah especially if you're a ground guy
yeah like it's hard to go and like take
shots and get takedowns
if your legs are comfortable you can't
jump off that leg or lunge off that leg
that was my question is how do you
defend against it like yeah
i mean that's what everyone holds a leg
kick yeah what you do is it's still
painful
instead of letting him kick you on the
like muscular part of your calf
you check what it called check the kick
so you turn your foot out so it goes
shin on shin
and both of you hit each other's shins
and you're both like [ __ ]
yeah i don't want to do my thing twice
if that happens twice 100 yeah you might
be like
if i want to do that again 100 100 i
think i'm in my memory i'm thinking back
izzy will do that
yeah he'll turn it out when we would
when we would like uh you know like you
know your fake
box with your friends not hitting in the
face but remember you do like body shots
or like shoulder shots you ever like do
that with your buddies
uh what i would do sometimes is i would
uh stick an
elbow out right we're not punching the
face but i just go like this with my
elbow if anybody's watching video you
can probably see it
and all it takes is your buddy punching
you in your elbow
once you're just punching bone before
they start realizing oh i don't want to
yeah that's not funny that's not funny
at all i need to be i'm not throwing
hard punches i can really hurt my hand
same effect can happen with the checks
so conor can regroup and he can like
learn how to like
check a kick better right okay
i just don't think it's worth it for him
i was hoping he would do well because
it'd be cool to see happy connor
fighting well but yeah as soon as i saw
he's all happy you're like yo i don't
think he's bro
he's not insecure enough
he's he is too confident in who he at
is as a person yeah and a man yeah he
has the confidence to exist he said
in the press conference there's a really
interesting point where he goes uh
uh the weird part is uh you know i know
i lost but i'm not that upset about it i
got to think about this
it's real like almost throwaway line
yeah and to me
that was the most important line of the
whole post-fight presser
he wasn't that upset about the loss he
didn't need the victory
in order to validate who he is as a man
he's validated through business he's
validated through family he's validated
through these other things
he didn't need the fight there's a time
where the fight was
all he had yeah he had to fight to get
out
now he's out now he's out but not only
do you have to fight to get out like
fighting was his identity right that was
the only thing that people appreciated
him for
when you build a 100 million dollar
business out of alcohol
people can go oh i really appreciate
this guy as a businessman yeah
you know maybe he has these other
endeavors that he's starting to do when
he
you know uh makes sure that like this
gym doesn't close in ireland he like
just paid off their debt because they
were really struggling because of kovid
and people go oh my god what an amazing
person just come in the last minute and
save it
people go wow you're a really sweet guy
and he goes yeah i am a pretty sweet guy
i don't need to kill people or you know
punch them in the face until they're
unconscious
in order to to feel validated yeah i
think
i think he realized that after his loss
against khabib is that he loses and goes
oh there's life after
this yes i like my legacy people still
love me i still walk around the street
and shut down the mall i'm so famous
like
i think he realized i think like the
perception is oh if i lose this
i'm no longer the best fighter like my
life is over and then he realized oh
life is great
life is still great i'm still loved
sorry to interrupt
the uh uh and it was a little different
than the the diaz fight
because i think in the diaz fight he
truly felt that he could beat
uh nate diaz he truly felt like he could
he's like yeah he tapped me out i got
tired that's on me
i to this day do not believe that he
believes he can beat khabib
and there is a difference there right he
knows khabib got him better like he's
just better
yeah and you can accept that yeah he
wants to be fight everyone you fight
watch could be by justin it was like
yeah i don't want this
even i don't know it's not even i don't
want this i just lost somebody better
i can't i can live with that weirdly
yeah this guy's just better like there's
nothing i could have done
if you if the nate diaz fight went away
andrew saying it's like bro i could have
[ __ ] got him
that's going to eat away at you there's
no way i could have got him he's just
better
what can you do yeah it's interesting
because he was
basically saying that he wasn't that
angry but he lost at least 100 million
dollars
when he lost that fight yep this is the
crazy thing
so i have on like pretty good
you know i trust worthy information that
he was gonna fight
pacquiao but that that was locked in but
he has to win this fight in order to
build up the interest to
to fight pacquiao that pacquiao fight is
worth tens of millions of dollars
yeah because if he beats pacquiao
he gets the welterweight belt it would
be for a championship
pacquiao has a belt he beat keith
thurman i think he's just been inactive
so imagine mcgregor crosses sports
somehow managed to squeak out a decision
over an aging pacquiao
forget it you're the biggest fight
you're the biggest fighter in history
yeah he's back on top khabib thing
doesn't even matter
who cares about khabib when you come
back now you have a fight with khabib
that's going to be worth crazy and
khabib probably would come back for that
yeah right not only that you take the
jake paul fight
i heard there was serious consideration
really yeah
so that's a 50 million dollar fight as
well minimum it's probably more
once you're the welterweight champion
right
now there's going to be significantly
less interest probably because if he
beats an actual boxer
then who cares about jake paul fighting
him right
but dude this guy lost at least a
hundred million maybe more 150 yeah
i mean it's like it's uh you're like who
wants to be a millionaire you know what
i mean like he
he was like three questions away from
being [ __ ] massive yeah but it's like
who wants to be a millionaire if
a millionaire is sitting in the chair
yeah and
what you said right there is the reason
why he's not that bummed and that tells
you everything
he's bum because he knows he's gonna
have to take the licks on the internet i
imagine
yeah and again this is me speculating i
don't [ __ ] know connor but like
it just seems to me and i'm kind of
happy about it that the guy is good with
his life
it's an ego blow and ego is born out of
insecurity and if you were secure and
you're confident yeah
it only hurts so much yeah you know i
was also thinking when you brought up
how much you made off proper 12. he made
100 million dollars
advertising going making appearances
body took no real punishment except
[ __ ] landing a plane
he really enjoyed it he was meeting
people 100 million
so you described he lost 100 million but
think of the abuse he has to take for a
hundred million yeah he's looking at his
daughter like i'm gonna take that many
shots in the head
boxing especially boxing is [ __ ]
devastating bang bang ba
i got a daughter i for the same amount
of money i've already got [ __ ] you money
i'm already good forever and i
i got a liquor brand that made me this
money no physical exertion yeah and he's
mad emotional too now like in
the press conference like someone asked
him a question there's like a real like
complimentary like kind of like
just like stroking question but it was
like you know you're taking the loss so
well like you must be
like you know you're trying to create an
example for your children blah blah blah
just like really buttering up
buttering him up about his kids and he
was like wow like you're really making
me well up right now like he
likes pause because he's gonna start
crying can change you more if you're
like a guy like that than anything yeah
like but he's like tapped in like
emotionally now like like i thought the
family [ __ ] was just kind of like
yeah and playing it up but i think he's
really about it i yeah i think that
connor is a really sophisticated guy and
i think that part of the reason why
we're so drawn to him is because he is
really attached to like who he is
as a man and i think that loss to khabib
like recognizing that he's not good
enough to beat khabib
he had to eat that he had to stomach
that he didn't have to stomach nick or i
mean nate
because he knew he could but he had to
accept that there was somebody he was
not going to be able to beat
and then when he did that he accepted
himself and all the great things that he
has and that was the
worst thing for him yeah the worst thing
for a fighter
is going i'm good enough the worst thing
for any creative is i'm good enough
you know it's just a tricky thing it's
hard when you achieve something that you
really want
and you're searching for the next
achievement right it's [ __ ]
it can be depressing sometimes you move
everyone to florida
no but in all seriousness like that but
in all seriousness we're going to
florida we're going to florida 100 miami
no but
in all series in his circumstance i
totally understand whether
he's better off for it he'll have a way
better career afterwards he won't be one
of these guys
50 years old trying to do comeback
fights himself he won't be [ __ ] the
wrestler or whatever that t
that movie was yeah but i also think
there is a maturation economy that's
happened like there was some thug [ __ ]
to him didn't he slap an old guy at a
bar
yeah throwing like the [ __ ] dolly
through the bus window i mean this guy
has some thug
[ __ ] to him but i think once you got
money you got something to
lose and you got a kid it's like where i
can't insecurity bro
yeah and i'm sorry and then he got
humbled yeah it's great this might not
be the best comparison but i just keep
thinking of charlemagne
interesting it's kind of like the same
kind of transformation he had
he's like rough around the edges a
little shock jack in the beginning
and like people loved him for it like we
were like glued to everything he was
doing
and then has pretty much almost [ __ ] you
money and it's like
and he's self-aware he's living for his
daughters now it's like he achieved
everything that he wanted to achieve and
then after doing that he realized oh
[ __ ] i still got to work on myself
achieving this alone is not going to
make me happy there's more to life
there's more to life and i gotta [ __ ]
work on that
in order to understand who i am and then
you understand who you are
and you're like oh [ __ ] i get to do this
because i love it but i don't have to
feed
this insatiable beast inside of me this
this insecurity
yeah it's it's uh i don't know i just i
hope he retired